BUT WE HAVE. TWO MEMBERS SERVING
TODAY AS TEMPORARY REPLACEMENTS
FOR TODAY'S HEARING, SENATOR
LARRY WHO IS NOT YET HERE, IS
REPLACING SENATOR MCGUIRE ON A
PERMANENT BASIS. SENATOR GROVE
IS REPLACING SENATOR SHOW BOGUE
ON A TEMPORARY BASIS TODAY, AND
SENATOR WILK WILL BE SERVING AS
THE VICE CHAIR TODAY AND SENATOR
COBOS ABSENCE. THERE ARE SIX
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA. TWO
BILLS ARE FOR RECONSIDERATION
AND ARE THEREFORE VOTE ONLY, UH
PER THE USUAL PRACTICE THOSE
BILLS ALRIGHT, I'M NUMBER ONE
AND NUMBER TWO BY SENATOR GROVE.
WE DO NOT YET HAVE A QUORUM. SO
LET'S BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
WITH THE FIRST REGULAR ORDER
BILL. WHICH IS GOING TO BE ME.
SENATOR. WE HAVE A MOTION TO
ADJOURN, MR GLASER. I GUESS
YOU'RE GETTING PREPARED TO GO TO
THE ASSEMBLY. BECAUSE THEY POOL
GAMES LIKE THAT OVER THERE, SO
WE'RE STILL IN THE SENATE,
THOUGH. YOU GET YOURSELF BOOKS,
MAYBE ONE QUÊ. ALWAYS HE'S
PRESENTING 14 0. WHAT'S THE
RECOMMENDATION? ALL RIGHT. HE'S
DOING ALL K¾T. WAS HE DOING?
NEWMAN FIRST DUE TO I'M GONNA DO
347 1ST AND ON BEHALF OF THAT'S
FINE, SO UP. NEXT IS FILE ITEM
SIX SP 347 BY OUR ESTEEMED CHAIR
. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
THAT FLOOR IS YOURS, SIR. THANK
YOU, SIR. THANK YOU, MR CHAIR.
GOOD MORNING. EXISTING LAW
AUTHORIZES THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHING CREDENTIALING TO ISSUE
CREDENTIALS FOR TEACHING
SPECIALTIES, INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS IN RESPONSE TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF UNIVERSAL TK
AND PRESCHOOL, THE
COMMISSIONER'S PRIORITIZED
EXPANSION EFFORTS WITH RESPECT
TO E CE, CALIFORNIA'S MASTER
PLAN FOR EARLY LEARNING AND CARE
CURRENTLY CALLS FOR THE CREATION
OF PREKINDERGARTEN THROUGH GRADE
THREE CREDENTIALS COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING RECENTLY
ADOPTED PROPOSED REGULATIONS TO
ESTABLISH THE PK THREE
SPECIALIST CONSTRUCTION
CREDENTIAL, WHICH IS DESIGNED TO
AUTHORIZED SERVICE IN
PREKINDERGARTEN THROUGH GRADE
THREE TO MEET THE NEEDS
PRESCHOOL IN TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN TEACHERS. SP 347
SIMPLY ACKNOWLEDGES IN STATUTE
THAT THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALS JURISDICTION NOW
INCLUDES THE AWARDING OF
CREDENTIALS FOR PRESCHOOL. AS
WELL AS FOR KINDERGARTEN THROUGH
GRADE 12. THIS BILL IS A MEASURE
TO CLEAN UP THE ED CODE TO
REFLECT THE UPDATED
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR EC AND DOES
NOT CREATE ANY NEW CREDENTIAL
BURDENS ON EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATORS. I'M RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR YOUR VOTE THIS
MORNING. THANK YOU, SIR. DO WE
HAVE ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT. SEEING NONE. ANY
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM AND
SUPPORT ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE. I THINK
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND ESTABLISH A
CORN FIRST AND THEN WE CAN GO TO
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS CONCERNS SO
WITH THAT CLERK NEWMAN NEWMAN
HERE WILL PRESENT WILL PRESENT
ORTEZ. GLASER GLASER HAIR GROVE
GROVE HERE, LAIRD. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS SMALLWOOD DRIVERS HERE.
WITH THAT WE HAVE A CORN.
PULLING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS CONCERNS.
THROUGH THE BELT. I HAVE A
MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL BY
SENATOR GLASER. WITH THAT, SIR,
YOU MAY CLOSE. APPRECIATE THAT
AGAIN. THIS THIS CREATES NO NEW
BURDENS SIMPLY HAD CLEANUP TO
REFLECT THE NEW CREDENTIAL
REQUIREMENT ASKING FOR MY VOTE
TODAY. THANK YOU, SIR. AND NOW
WE'LL TAKE ROLL. FILE ITEM. SIX
SB 347 NEWMAN MOTION IS DUE PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
NEWMAN NEWMAN. I WILL. I WILL I
ORTEZ. GLASER GLASER, I, GROVE
GROVE. I LAIRD I SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS? AYE.
ALRIGHT THAT'S SIX VOTES, SO
IT'S OUT. WE WILL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OUTSTANDING MEMBERS AND
AGAIN, IT'S DO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS. NOW WE'RE MOVING
TO FILE ITEMS FOR SB 691 SENATOR
PORTANTINO. THE MOTION IS DO
PASS THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AND WITH THAT FLOOR
AGAIN AS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR
CHAIR, MR CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
PORTANTINO, REPRESENTING SP 691
LET ME BEGIN BY EXPLICITLY
ACCEPTING ON HIS BEHALF. THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS CURRENTLY FROM AMONG
THE CANDIDATES PRESENTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS. ONLY ONE
STUDENT MEMBER IS APPOINTED BY
THE GOVERNOR. THIS BILL WOULD
INCREASE THAT NUMBER FROM 1 TO
3. IT IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION TO
CONSIDER AND ADOPT VARIOUS
REGULATIONS AND STANDARDS THAT
GOVERN THE STATE'S PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM AND ADAPT CURRICULUM
FRAMEWORKS FOR GRADES K THROUGH
12. THE GOAL OF SPT 691 IS TO
FACILITATE A GREATER VOICE FOR
STUDENTS SO THAT THEY CAN
DIRECTLY ENGAGE IN THESE
IMPORTANT POLICY DISCUSSIONS AND
THEREBY CONTRIBUTE TO BETTER
POLICIES WHICH AFFECT
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEMS AND ITS STUDENTS,
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF STUDENT
REPRESENTATIVE 123 WILL MAKE A
MEANINGFUL DIFFERENCE IN
ENSURING THAT STUDENT VOICES ARE
HEARD AND THAT STUDENT INTERESTS
ARE CONSIDERED IN WAYS THAT
ENSURE A BETTER AND MORE
INCLUSIVE SYSTEM WITHIN
CALIFORNIA EDUCATIONAL SYSTEMS.
IT IS FOR THESE REASONS THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I VOTE THIS
MORNING. THANK YOU. ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ANY
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM AT ALL. GET
READY TO GO. BUELLER BUELLER. UM
OKAY WITH THAT, LET'S PULL IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. FOR ANY
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS. YOU CAN
HELP. GLASER ONCE AGAIN MOVES
ABILITIES, THE NEW SENATOR
ARCHULETTA, SO CONGRATS ON THAT.
ANY COMMENTS AT ALL WITH THAT GO
AHEAD AND CLOSE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR PORTANTINO. I'M
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR YOUR
THANK YOU, SIR. WITH THAT. LET'S
CALL THE ROLL. FINAL ITEM FOR SB
691 PORTANTINO MOTION IS DUE
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
. NEWMAN NEWMAN, I WILK WILL
KNOW ORTEZ. GLASER GLASER I
GROVE GROVE NOTE LAIRD LURED. I
SMALLWOOD GUAVAS GUAVAS? AYE.
THE RIGHT WORDS. SO THAT'S 4 TO
4 TO 2 WILL LEAVE THE ROYAL
OPEN. YOU KNOW, DOING THE NEXT
ONE, SIR? NO. FOR THE NEXT ONE
TO ROLL. I SHOOT. YOU'RE NOT
DOING CENTER. CORTEZ IS OKAY NOW
I'M HANDING THE GAVEL BACK TO
YOU. THAT'S GOOD. ALRIGHT WELL
DONE BY THE VICE CHAIR.
HOPEFULLY I CAN MAINTAIN HIS
STANDARD. UM AND NOW, NEXT, WITH
THE TWO BILLS TO BE RECONSIDERED
. THESE ARE VOTE ONLY AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER. THOSE BILLS
ARE NUMBER ONE AND TWO CENTER
GROVE. WE'RE READY TO TAKE THOSE
UP. MADAM CHAIR. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MADAM CLERK. WE DO NEED A
MOTION. I'M SORRY I MOVE MOTION
FOR SENATOR WILK. MADAM CLERK.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM.
ONE SB 292 GROWTH MOTION IS TO
PASS TO GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN NO NEWMAN, NO
WILK, WILK ORTEZ. LASER LASER NO
GROWTH. GROVE I LAIRD MARRIED?
NO SMALLWOOD QUIVERS DRIVERS
KNOW DID WE VOTE ON BOTH AT ONCE
YOU 27 AND THE NEXT BILL, PLEASE
TÔI FIVE GROVE MOTION IS BE
ADOPTED AND RE REFERRED TO THE
ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS COMMITTEE. NEWMAN
NEWMAN, NO WILK, CORTEZ BLAZER.
GLASER. NO GROWTH. I LAIRD LEARN
NO SMALL WITH CUEVAS CUEVAS NOW.
VERY GOOD. WE'LL LEAVE THOSE
BOTH OPEN. WE'VE GOT FOUR NOSE
TO TWO YESES FOR BOTH OF THOSE
BILLS. AND NOW WE ARE WAITING ON
TWO AUTHORS, SENATOR SKINNER AND
SENATOR CURTIS. I'VE ALWAYS
THOUGHT THIS WOULD BE THE TIME
LIKE ON A REALITY TV SHOW WE
SHOULD HAVE, LIKE A CROWD
WARMER, UPPER KEEP YOU ALL
ENTERTAINED. NO SENATOR. WHAT
COULD DO THAT IF YOU WANTED TO
AND WE'LL LET BOTH OF THOSE
MEMBERS IN OTHER WAITING FOR
THEM.
GOOD MORNING. WELCOME, SENATOR
SKINNER. PLEASE DO NOT RUSH, BUT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY, DO NOT
RUSH. SENATOR SKINNER WILL BE
PRESENTING SP 56. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY, YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR. CHAIR
MEMBERS. UM F 356 IS PURPOSE IS
TO ALLOW THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AT BERKELEY. HE
TRANSFER OWNERSHIP. ARE THEY
STUDENT HOUSING FACILITY CALLED
THE ROACH DALE APARTMENTS TO THE
BERKELEY STUDENT COOPERATIVE
ASSOCIATION. THE BERKELEY
STUDENT COOPERATIVE ASSOCIATION,
WHICH IS B. S. C. C. UM HAS
OPERATED ROACH DALE FROM IT'S
FROM THE DAY IT OPENED. UM THE
ORGANIZATION ITSELF. WAS FOUNDED
IN 1933. IT'S THE LARGEST
STUDENT COOPERATIVE ASSOCIATION
HOUSING COOPERATIVE IN THE
UNITED STATES, AND IT HOUSES NOW
AND THEIR VARIOUS FACILITIES.
1300 STUDENTS. UM SO, AS I
POINTED OUT THIS, UH THE LAND
AND SOME OF THE CONSTRUCTION
COSTS. THE BUILDING ORIGINALLY
WERE INVESTED BY YOU SEE, BUT
THE STUDENT COOPERATIVE
ASSOCIATION HAS MANAGED IT FROM
THE DAY IT OPENED. SO THIS WAS
IN THE EARLY SEVENTIES AND WHAT
THE UNIVERSITY WANTS TO TRANSFER
THAT OWNERSHIP TO ALLOW BSC TO
BE ABLE TO GET STREAMLINED
APPROVALS FOR NEW FINANCING TO
UPGRADE THE BUILDING BECAUSE THE
BUILDING IS IN NEED OF UPGRADE,
SO THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THE
BILL, AND, UH, WE HAVE TO DO IT
STATUTORILY BECAUSE OF SOME RULE
IN CODE. UM AND I WANT TO CALL
MY WITNESSES, WHICH ARE JASON
MURPHY FROM, UH, YOU SEE, OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT, AND, UH, SIGN
GÓMEZ FROM THE BERKELEY STUDENT
COOPERATIVE ASSOCIATION. MR.
MURPHY PLEASE COME FORWARD.
WE'RE BACK TO THE WAY IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE USING THE TABLE.
YEAH WELCOME. PLEASE PROCEED. MR
CHAIR AND MEMBERS JASON MURPHY
ON BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA PROUD TO BE HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL,
AS SENATOR NOTED, THE
UNIVERSITY'S SOLE INTEREST HERE
IS ENSURING THAT AFFORDABLE
ADEQUATE HOUSING REMAINS
AVAILABLE IN THE BERKELEY
COMMUNITY. UM UNIVERSITY,
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN LEASING THIS
PROPERTY TO, UH, THE BERKELEY
STUDENT COOPERATIVE FOR OVER 50
YEARS AND A DOLLAR PER YEAR. OUR
INTEREST HERE IS ONLY ENSURING
THAT IT CONTINUE TO BE SERVED TO
SERVE AS STUDENT HOUSING.
HOWEVER BECAUSE THE SEISMIC
ISSUES IT WILL BE MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE FOR THE COOPERATIVE TO
FUND AND PERFORM THOSE DUTIES.
AROUND SEISMIC ISSUES IF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO HOLD THE TITLE TO
THE LAND, SO THIS BILL SIMPLY
ALLOWS US TO TRANSFER THE TITLE
TO ENSURE AND TO PROTECT THE
REGION'S INTERESTS. IT WOULD BE
DONE UNDER A REVERSION ERI GRANT
DEED SO THAT IF IT WERE TO NOT
BE USED FOR STUDENT HOUSING IN
THE IN THE FUTURE FOR ANY REASON
IT WOULD REVERT BACK TO THE
UNIVERSITY'S INTEREST. BUT FOR
NOW, WE BELIEVE THAT GIVEN THE
50 YEAR TRACK RECORD WERE VERY
ASSURED THAT IT WILL CONTINUE TO
BE USED IN THE WAY IT'S BEEN
INTENDED IN THE PAST AND AGAIN
PROUD TO BE SUPPORTED THE BILL.
I APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU.
PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS SAYING
MACIAS GÓMEZ I'M THE BERKELEY
STUDENT COOPERATIVE VICE
PRESIDENT OF EXTERNAL AFFAIRS
AND I'M HONORED TO BE SPEAKING
WITH YOU ALL ON SB 56 AS A
MEMBER OF ROCKDALE MYSELF, THE
LAND TRANSFER IS DEEPLY PERSONAL
TO MY WELLNESS AS A MEMBER AND
STUDENT, THE BS CS SERVED AS A
SAFE HARBOR FOR èC. BERKELEY'S
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS LIKE
MYSELF FOR THE LAST 50 YEARS AND
THE LAST 90 YEARS OF OUR
ORGANIZATION AS B 56 IS A
CRUCIAL STEP IN THE INVESTMENT
OF THE COOPERATIVE MOVEMENT, AND
THIS IS THE FIRST STEP IN
DEMONSTRATING THE STATE'S
SUPPORT FOR THE LARGEST HOUSING
STUDENT COOPERATIVE IN NORTH
AMERICA. THE BERKELEY STUDENT
COOPERATIVE IS A 501 C THREE
MEMBER AND STUDENT RUN, UM,
NONPROFIT THAT PROVIDES LOW COST
HOUSING AND FOOD TO èC
BERKELEY'S STUDENTS THROUGH
COLLABORATIVE AND COMMUNAL
HOUSING. THE BSC PROVIDES THE
NEEDS OF LOW INCOME STUDENTS AND
SERVES THE MEMBERS, REGARDLESS
OF SOCIOECONOMIC STATUS. WHAT
MAKES ROCKDALE SO SPECIAL IS THE
FACT THAT IT IS THE IT IS AN
APARTMENT BUILDING, OFFERING 259
BEDS TO SOME OF BERKELEY'S MOST
LOW INCOME STUDENTS. HOUSING
STUDENTS BETWEEN $600,000 PER
MONTH WHICH IS SURPRISINGLY AN
ASTONISHING LOWER THAN WHAT
ANYWHERE ELSE YOU WOULD FIND IN
THE BAY. OUT OF OUR 20 UNITS,
ROCKS DYLAN FENWICK ARE HOME TO
SOME OF THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF
LOW INCOME, DISABLED AND
STUDENTS OF COLOR. FORM 90 YEARS
AGO TO HELP POOR STUDENTS IN
1933 ACCESS, HOUSING, FOOD AND
COMMUNITY BY UTILIZING
COOPERATIVE ECONOMIES. THE BSC
CONTINUES TO PROVIDE QUALITY,
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND IS ONE OF
THE ONE OF THE LAST REMAINING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPTIONS FOR
BERKELEY STUDENTS TODAY AND THE
BEGINNING OF 2022 ARE LEAST WITH
èC BERKELEY HAD BEEN EXPIRED
AND THE èC WAS BEGINNING THE
LEAST NEGOTIATIONS WITH US. AND
WE WERE TASKED WITH 15 $16
MILLION WORTH OF SEISMIC
RETROFITTING ON AN EXPEDITED
TIMELINE. LET'S PUT THE BSC
BETWEEN A ROCK AND A HARD PLACE,
POTENTIALLY LOSING OVER 150
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS TO AN
INSTITUTION THAT HAS
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED IT'S
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS IN THE
SEARCH FOR PROFIT HOUSING
ALTERNATIVES OR THE BSC WOULD BE
FORCED TO RAISE RATES ON ITS
OVER 1200 MEMBERS TO PROVIDE THE
REQUIRED FINANCES FOR THE
EXPEDITED RETROFITS. THEIR
COOPERATION AND A TIRELESS LABOR
OF THE SAVE ROCKDALE COALITION
AND THE NEGOTIATIONS TEAM. WE
FIND OURSELVES HERE TODAY BEFORE
THE LEGISLATURE ASKING FOR YOU
YOUR COOPERATION AS WELL IN THE
PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT THE CO
OPS ARE ABLE TO SUSTAIN
THEMSELVES WERE PLANNING THIS
LARGE SCALE RETROFITTING AS B 56
WILL ALLOW THE BSC TO PROCEED
WITH HOUSING STUDENTS THAT ARE
THE HIGHEST NEED IN THE BAY
AREA. AND BEGINNING ITS INITIAL
STAGES AND DEVELOPING A
COOPERATIVE ECONOMY AMONGST THE
BSC, THE STATE LEGISLATURE AND
THE èC. THAT CAN BE NURTURED TO
SUSTAIN THE WELLNESS OF ALL LOW
INCOME STUDENTS IN THE BAY AREA
AND HOPEFULLY ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AS A 2020 2023 ARTICLE FROM
MERCURY NEWS NOTES. THE TELLY OF
HOMELESS STUDENTS IN THE BAY
AREA INCREASED 20 NO 30% BETWEEN
2019 AND 2020. AND WE MUST
INTERVENE TO INVEST IN
COOPERATIVE HOUSING AT THIS
POINT. IT IS FAR TOO LATE
ALREADY. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
LISTENING TO WHAT I HAVE TO SAY
ON SB 56 AND WE, THE BERKELEY
STUDENT COOPERATIVE, URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT SB 56 TO ENSURE THAT LOW
INCOME STUDENTS IN THE BAY AREA
ARE RETAINED AND SUPPORTED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES HE WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
OF SHOW. PLEASE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE AND STATE, YOUR NAME,
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION. SEEING NONE DO IT. I
MEAN WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
THE MEASURE. SAYING THAT NO ONE
IS THAT ALL OKAY? LET US BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FOR
SOONER SKIN IT WE'VE GOT A
MOTION FROM SENATOR GLASER.
SENATOR, I JUST WANT TO NOTE
THAT THIS IS A PROVIDES AN
EXEMPTION TO THE STOLE ACT.
WHICH IS UNPRECEDENTED BUT
NECESSARY. AND YOU MAY TOUCH ON
THIS BECAUSE, BUT, YOU KNOW, I'D
SAY THIS IS A CREATIVE SOLUTION
TO A PRESSING PROBLEM. GLAD TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. IF YOU'D LIKE
TO CLOSE. I APPRECIATE THAT, UM,
CHAIR. YES, IT IS. THE
STALACTITE DIDN'T GIVE THAT
SPECIFIC, BUT, UM AND, UH, WE
WOULDN'T AS HAS BEEN EXPLAINED
TO BE ASKING IT. UH EXCEPT FOR
THE FACT THAT BY, UM YOU SEE
THESE CONTINUAL OWNERSHIP
HANDICAPS. THE UH, STUDENT
COOPERATIVE ASSOCIATION FROM
BEING WILL GET THE FINANCING TO
DO THAT REPAIRS SO AS HAS BEEN
PRESENTED, THAT'S THE WAY TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS, AND I THINK
IT'S A GOOD WAY. AND IT ALSO
ENSURES BOTH WITH THE HOW THE
UNIVERSITY WROTE THE TRANSFER.
LEGALLY THAT IF FOR ANY REASON,
THE B S C C WERE TO STOP
OPERATING DECIDE NOT TO. IT
WOULD GO BACK TO YOU SEE, SO WE
COULD CONTINUE TO HAVE IT. IN
THE, UH, YOU KNOW, AS AVAILABLE
STUDENT HOUSING. SO, UM, I LIVED
IN B S C C HOUSING. WHEN I WAS
AN UNDERGRAD WAS ONE OF THE WAYS
I WAS ABLE TO AFFORD A SCHOOL.
THAT'S REALLY FANTASTIC. THIS
COOPERATIVE ASSOCIATION WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK
YOU. AND WITH THAT WE HAVE
EMOTION FROM SENATOR GLASER.
MADAM CLERK. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM. THREE SB 56
SKINNER MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE NEWMAN.
I WILL. I WILL CORTEZ CORTEZ. EI
GLASER GLASER I, GROVE GROVE. I
LURED. SMALLWOOD QUIVERS.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS? AYE. VERY GOOD
, AND THAT BRINGS US TO OUR
FINAL BILL IS THE MORNING
SENATOR. COURTESY. I BELIEVE
YOU'RE NOT. NO I'M SORRY. SO AND
THAT'S SO THAT S P 56. WE'RE
STILL SCHOOL. LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
SUNDERLAND. YOU MAY PURSUE WHEN
READY, SENATOR. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I'M HERE
TO PRESENT SP 43 THIS MORNING
BILL PROHIBITING PRONE RESTRAINT
, THE TECHNIQUE THAT PHYSICALLY
OR MECHANICALLY RESTRAINED
STUDENTS IN A FACEDOWN POSITION
IN ALL CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS.
CALIFORNIA LAW CURRENTLY ALLOWS
PRONE RESTRAINT TO BE USED IN
SCHOOLS BY TRAINED PERSONNEL AND
STIPULATES THAT THE STUDENTS
HANDS CAN'T BEHOLD BEHIND THEIR
BACK. STAFF MUST ALSO OBSERVE
THE PEOPLE FOR ANY SIGNS OF
PHYSICAL DISTRESS. THROUGHOUT
ITS USE. EVEN WITH THOSE
SAFEGUARDS, THIS TECHNIQUE IS
STILL ONE OF THE MOST DANGEROUS
RESTRAINTS USED IN SCHOOLS
BECAUSE IT RESTRICTS THE
STUDENTS AIRWAY AND HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO BE FATAL. DESPITE
THE U. S DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
, RECOMMENDING ITS ELIMINATION
PRONE RESTRAINT IS UNFORTUNATELY
STILL IN PRACTICE IN SOME
STATES, INCLUDING CALIFORNIA,
ACCORDING TO CALIFORNIA, THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THEATER, TEAMED FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S WEBER'S PASSAGE
OF A B 2657. IN THE 2022 2023
SCHOOL YEAR. CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
USE PHYSICAL RESTRAINTS ON
STUDENTS. 6785 TIMES, JUST 14%
OF THE STUDENT POPULATION
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
ENDURED 95.5% OF THOSE PHYSICAL
RESTRAINTS. MOREOVER, PRONE
RESTRAINTS ARE APPLIED AT A
HIGHER RATE AGAINST BLACK
STUDENTS, ACCORDING TO FINDINGS
BY THE SACRAMENTO BEE SP 43 6 TO
PROHIBIT THE USE OF RESTRAINT IN
CALIFORNIA. AND JOIN THE MORE
THAN 30. OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
TAKEN THE NECESSARY STEPS TO
PROTECT CHILDREN FROM THE
DANGERS OF THIS TECHNIQUE. IN
2018. 13 YEAR OLD MAX BENSON.
TRAGICALLY PASSED AWAY AT AN
ELDORADO HILLS SCHOOL AFTER
BEING HELD IN A PRONE EXTREME
FOR AN HOUR. WE'RE HONORED TO BE
JOINED HERE TODAY BY MAX'S
MOTHER. AS A PARENT. AND HIS
PARENTS, MANY OF US IT'S VERY,
VERY DIFFICULT TO IMAGINE WHAT
SHE'S GONE THROUGH. YOUR VOTE
TODAY WILL HONOR MAX'S MEMORY,
OF COURSE, BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY,
PERHAPS HELP ENSURE THAT SIMILAR
TRAGEDIES NEVER OCCUR AGAIN.
WITH US TODAY WE HAVE STATIONED
AT LANGLEY, MAX'S MAX, PENCE'S
MOTHER. ADDITIONALLY HERE AS A
TECHNICAL WITNESSES, DR MILLER
TO MINEAU IS THE CO FOUNDER AND
PRINCIPAL AT POOR VIEW,
PREPARATORY. THANK YOU, MR CHAIR
AND SENATORS RESPECT WE ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU, MISS
LANGLEY. PLEASE COME FORWARD.
AND WELCOME. AND PLEASE COME TO
THE TABLE TO THE TABLE. WE'RE
GLAD TO HAVE YOU HERE TO DO
WELCOME. THANKS FOR HAVING ME
HERE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU HAVE
TO HIT THE BUTTON ON THE
MICROPHONE, OKAY? VERY GOOD. I
HAVE A TINY VOICE. AND IF I TRY
TO FORCE IT ON SOUND LIKE A
GOOSE, SO FORGIVE ME. UM MY NAME
IS STATION LANGLEY. I HAVE LIVED
IN DAVIS MOST OF MY LIFE AND I
GRADUATED FROM UC DAVIS. MY
CHILDREN ATTENDED THE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS THERE. I AM HERE TO
EXPRESS MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR SV
FOR 83 BECAUSE MY SON MAX,
CANNOT IN 2018. HE WAS KILLED BY
A TEACHER WHO PUT HIM IN A PRONE
RESTRAINT. HIS CLASSMATES
WATCHED. UM WHAT THE LIFE
DRAINED OUT OF HIM FOR OVER THE
COURSE OF 30 OR 40 MINUTES, I
THINK UM, IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO
ADEQUATELY DESCRIBE WHAT IT'S
LIKE TO LOSE A CHILD, ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU KNOW THAT THEY DIED A
SLOW, PAINFUL AND TERRIFYING
DEATH. AT THE HANDS OF SOMEBODY
WHO WAS SUPPOSED TO EDUCATE AND
CARE FOR HIM. MAX WAS BRIGHT AND
HILARIOUS, KID. HE COULD DO MORE
THAN LIGHT UP THE ROOM. HE LIT
UP OUR ENTIRE LIVES. EVERY
MEMBER OF OUR FAMILY STRUGGLES
DAILY. WITH THE DARKNESS CREATED
BY HIS ABSENCE. IF THIS BILL HAD
BEEN ENACTED AND ENFORCED IN THE
FALL OF 2018 MAX WOULD BE ALIVE
TODAY. PRONE RESTRAINT IS
BARBARIC AND DEADLY. AND I HAVE
NO DOUBT THAT THE NEXT YOUNG
VICTIM IS SITTING IN A
CALIFORNIA CLASSROOM THIS
MORNING. AND I URGE EVERYONE TO
HELP SAVE THAT CHILD'S LIFE BY
SUPPORTING SP 43. THANK YOU,
MADAM. SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS.
DOCTOR TO ME OR ANYTHING. THEY
HAD YES, CHAIR AND SENATORS. I
AM DR MELORA ERICKSON TOMATO,
AND I'M, A BOARD CERTIFIED
BEHAVIOR ANALYST AND CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGIST. I HAVE SERVED
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES FOR
25 YEARS AND SERVE AS THE CO
FOUNDER AND PRINCIPAL AT PORTS
PREPARATORY, A NON PUBLIC SCHOOL
THAT SERVES OVER 50, CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHO RELY ON US
TO EDUCATE THEIR STUDENTS WHO
DEMONSTRATE THE MOST SEVERE,
CHALLENGING BEHAVIORS AND WHO
REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS MY PARTNER, DR EDWARD
MIGUEL AND I HAVE NEVER ALLOWED
THE USE OF PRONE RESTRAINTS AT
PORTS VIEW AS WE SAW FIRSTHAND
HOW DANGEROUS THESE TECHNIQUES
ARE AND RECOGNIZE THAT EDUCATORS
HAVE AN ETHICAL OBLIGATION TO
IMPLEMENT EVIDENCE BASED
INTERVENTIONS PRONE RESTRAINT IS
NOT SUPPORTED BY PEER REVIEWED
RESEARCH AND HAS NO THERAPEUTIC
BENEFIT. OVER THE YEARS IN
EDUCATIONAL SETTINGS WERE PRONE
TO STRENGTH IS UTILIZED. WE HAVE
SEEN TRAGEDY AFTER TRAGEDY
OCCURRED DUE TO AN OVER RELIANCE
ON RESTRAINT RATHER THAN
INTERVENTION, FORCED COMPLIANCE
RATHER THAN UNDERSTANDING AND
OUTDATED RESPONSES RATHER THAN
EXPERTISE. ALLOWING PRONE
RESTRAINT CREATES A CULTURE THAT
PROMOTES A POWER DIFFERENTIAL.
WE'RE PRONE RESTRAINT BECOMES
THE FIRST AND ONLY INTERVENTION
USED. EVEN WHEN PERFORMED BY
TRAINED PERSONNEL, IT IS OFTEN
STILL DONE INCORRECTLY. AND
DANGEROUSLY. NOT ONLY DOES PRONE
RESTRAINT, POST SERIOUS RISKS TO
OUR STUDENTS. IT IS ALSO OVER,
UTILIZED WITH STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND IN A STATE THAT
PROMOTES DIVERSITY AND EQUALITY.
EDUCATORS ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
RESTRAINING STUDENTS OF COLOR,
ESPECIALLY BLACK STUDENTS. 37
STATES HAVE BANNED PRONE
RESTRAINT. CALIFORNIA HAS NOT
THE RISKS OF NOT ADOPTING THIS
BILL ARE TOO GREAT. I URGE YOU
TO IMAGINE YOUR CHILD NIECE,
NEPHEW OR GRANDCHILD. IMAGINE
THEM HEADING OFF TO SCHOOL. NOW
IMAGINE THEM LAYING FACE DOWN
THERE LAST WORDS, I CAN'T
BREATHE THEIR BEDROOM EMPTY AS
THEY WILL NEVER RETURN.
CALIFORNIA CAN DO BETTER. LET'S
NOT LOSE ANOTHER LIFE. PLEASE
KEEP OUR STUDENTS SAFE AND PASS.
SB 483 THANK YOU, SENATOR
COURTESY FOR THIS VERY IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE IN THE WITNESS ROOM LIKE
TESTIFYING SUPPORTED THE
MEASURE? IF SO, PLEASE COME
FORWARD. AND ASK YOU TO STATE
YOUR NAME. YOUR ORGANIZATION,
YOUR POSITION. NICOLE WARD
HERMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU, MR WATERMAN.
ERIC HARRIS. WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS, CALIFORNIA STRONG
SUPPORT AND SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT. GOOD MORNING,
RACHEL BHAGWAT ON BEHALF OF THE
KLU, CALIFORNIA ACTION AND
SUPPORTED THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
JIMMY FROM GIN ON BEHALF OF
RESPECTABILITY WHERE NATIONAL
DISABILITY NONPROFIT AND WE'RE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. JENNIFER
ABERNATHY. I'M A FRIEND OF THE
FAMILY AND AN ADVOCATE. AND I'M
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
BRENDAN WHITE. I AM ALSO A
NEIGHBOR AND A FRIEND OF
LANGLEY'S AND MAX BENSON HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU,
SIR. DUSTIN COLLIER, FOUNDING
PARTNER OF CIVIL RIGHTS LAW
FIRM, CALL YOUR SOCKS, ELOPE AND
ATTORNEY FOR THE LANGUAGE FAMILY
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS,
BILL. THANK YOU. ELIZABETH MALAY
PARTNER AT COLLIER STOCKS, CIVIL
RIGHTS LAW FIRM, STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. ALSO A FRIEND OF
THE FAMILY FAMILY. THANK YOU. UM
ANYBODY ELSE KNEW IT WAS GONNA
BE HERE LIKE TESTIFYING
OPPOSITION OF THE MEASURE.
SEEING NONE. LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
GONNA MOTION FOR SENATOR GLASER?
I'M SORRY, SENATOR. SMALLER
CRATERS. PLEASE JUST WANTED TO
SAY TO THE TWO WITNESSES AND
EXPERTS TODAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR COURAGE FOR YOUR STORY
AND SHARING. UM THAT EXPERIENCE
TO EDUCATE OTHERS WAS VERY
MOVING AND ALSO SHED SOME REAL
DETAIL ON THE IMPACTS OF THIS
PRACTICE. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE. AND THEN LET ME
ADD TO THE FRIENDS OF THE FAMILY
WHO CAME OUT TODAY. THANK YOU.
NOT AN EASY THING TO DO. UM, WE
HAVE A MOTION. DO WE HAVE A
MOTION? OKAY, ARCHULETTA. I'M
SORRY. I REALLY DID MISS IT,
SENATOR GLACIER, YOU MOVE THE
BILL. APOLOGIZE EMOTION, SENATOR
GLASER, SECRETARY WOULD WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? BUT YES, MR
CHERIF, FIRST OF ALL AGAIN JUST
TO THINK THE WITNESSES. UH MISS
LANGLEY FOR HER COURAGE ON
BEHALF OF MILLIONS LITERALLY
MILLIONS OF STUDENTS CURRENTLY
AND THOSE TO COME IN FUTURE
GENERATIONS TO STAND UP AND
SPEAK TO COME HERE TO THE
COMMITTEE. UM. WAS SUCH MOVING
TESTIMONY. AS ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES JUST SAID. UM THIS IS
BEYOND ADMIRABLE. THANK YOU FOR
THAT. AND ALTHOUGH MISS LANGLEY
WASN'T THE SOURCE OF THE BILL,
IDEA, ALL OF US HERE AS SENATORS
KIND OF REFER TO HOW THESE
THINGS START. SOMETIMES IT'S
BILL IDEAS. IT WAS UM, AN
ACTIVIST MEMBER OF THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY IN MY OWN
DISTRICT, WHO ASKED ME TO MEET
WITH HIM AT A STARBUCKS. ONE DAY
HE BEGAN TO RECOUNT WHAT
HAPPENED TO HIM. HE SURVIVED.
WOULD OTHERWISE BE A SIMILAR
EPISODE. AS YOU MIGHT IMAGINE
HIS OWN TESTIMONY TO ME THAT
DAY. AS HE IN FITS AND STARTS
TRIED TO PRESENT BUT WHAT HE
WANTED TO SEE HAPPEN, UM WAS WAS
ITSELF VERY, VERY EMOTIONAL AND
QUITE MOVING, AND I THINK ANY MY
COLLEAGUES HERE WOULD HAVE DONE
WHAT I DID AND QUICKLY EXCEPT
RESPONSIBILITY FOR BRINGING THE
BILL FORWARD. SO WITH THAT, I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU, MADAM CLERK. WE
HAVE EMOTIONS. SENATOR GLACIER,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FINALLY
ADAM FIVE. SB 483 COURT. EASY
MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE NEWMAN
NEWMAN, I WILK, WILK, CORTEZ,
CORTEZ. EI GLASER GLASER I,
GROVE GROVE. AYE LAIRD GLARED
EYES. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS SMALL,
AYE. HMM THAT BILL IS OUT SIX
VOTES TO ZERO. UM AND LET US
KNOW. I'M SURE MRS SYMBOLS TO
ZERO. THANK YOU. AND I THINK WE
HAVE A COUPLE OF OPEN VOTES. AT
LEAST ONE, SIR MADAM CLERK ON ON
ANY OPEN MEASURES. IF YOU COULD
PLEASE IDENTIFY THE BUILDING
CALLED THE ROLE. FILE ITEM ONE
IS BETWEEN 92 GROWTH MOTION IS
DUE PAST THE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS FOR NOSE AND TWO EYES
WITH THE CHAIR OF VOTING. NO
ORTEZ. AH SP 292 GROWTH. OKAY?
THAT FEELS THAT BILL FAILS WITH
TWO YES VOTES AND FOUR NO VOTES.
OKAY FINE. LET THEM TO S A FIVE
GROWTH MOTIONS AS WE ADOPTED AND
REFERRED TO ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS
COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTE IS FOR
NOSE AND TWO EYES, ORTEZ. OKAY
THAT BILL FAILS WITH TWO YEARS'
VOTES AND FOUR NO VOTES. OKAY?
OKAY? FOLLOWING. UM THREE SB 56
SKINNER MOTION IS DUE PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE VOTED
SIX SIZE AND NO NOS LAIRD I THAT
BILL IS OUT SEVEN VOTES TO ZERO.
FINAL ITEM FOR SB 691 PORTANTINO
MOTION IS DO PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND
CRIME VOTE IS FOUR EYES AND TWO
NOTES WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
CORTEZ CORTEZ EI. THAT BILL IS
ABOUT FIVE VOTES TO. OKAY UM
ADAM SIX SP 347 NEWMAN MOTION IS
DUE PASSED THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CRIME VOTED SIX EYES
AND NO NOSE WITH THE CHAIR.
VOTING I CORTEZ CORTEZ EI, AND
THAT BILL IS OUT SEVEN VOTES TO
ZERO THAT CLOSES AT OUR AGENDA
FOR TODAY. THANK YOU TO ALL THE
WITNESSES. THANK YOU TO STAFF.
WITH THAT THE SENATE COMMITTEE
EDUCATION IS ADJOURNED.